there is a group of people in this
extraordinary time whose role and whose
compassion has not been a focus that
must be recognized this is Sean and this
is Eliot from a funeral home in nany key
they're heading into the Warwickshire
countryside for the latest of so many
collections over the past few weeks not
all are confirmed Kovac cases but these
days the respectful formality of this
process must be hidden underneath white
suits the team here have invited us in
because they want us to know that even
in the most challenging of times they're
doing their best to provide support for
the bereaved and dignity for the dead a
list of the outstanding doctors and
green certificates that were waiting for
Daniel is the boss here a family firm
for three generations if you're
struggling the message in the morning
meeting is bluntly that there is now a
significant backlog from the Easter
weekend listen I know it's been a little
bit exceptional but thank you for for
the hard work and the commitment it is
very much appreciated at the back the
arrivals continue
the mortuary here is almost full
it's Gary who prepares the new coffins
and Alana who embalm deceased it's just
crazy
all the sensitivities been taken out of
a funeral there's just it's unbelievable
never known anything good like it oh
yeah are you heading out again now yeah
we're going out again yeah another
private address that's two so far today
there's always always hope that there
might not be anyone else that needs our
care but if that's the way it goes then
we're more than happy to lunch time they
were expecting a delivery of 30 coffins
it hasn't arrived though there is a
shortage with the supplier we'll
reassess things okay there's never a
good time to lose someone but during
this period it just you know makes the
whole process so so much more difficult
but inside in the office there is a calm
professionalism from a team who must be
exhausted in every way Paperclip Ward
here is a family bereaved and for Daniel
this is now tragically personal through
Kovac 19 my uncle sadly passed away he'd
been battling with the virus for just
over two weeks our family amongst
professional commitments have also got a
family bereavement to look after we'll
do all we can to to give my uncle there
the dignified send-off he deserves but
again it will be with a great level of
restrictions
as they prepare for many more days of
this what we have found here has not
been despair but a reassurance that
should be a comfort for many of us
mark stone Sky News in Nuneaton